lindsay starts us off this hour in los
angeles hi lindsay how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
so i was involved in a crosstalk in
february
uh praise the lord i'm okay my baby's
okay but my car was totaled
um i got a settlement for about ten
thousand
i believe it was about ten thousand
seven hundred and i tithed on it gave
the ten percent to the lord
and i have left about uh nine thousand
five
and my husband and i have 12 000 about
14 000
in debt and i'm wondering if i use that
settlement money to pay off that debt or
do i save it
to get a new car okay so
the car you were driving the car you
were driving that was totaled
was worth how much um
i believe it was worth about ten
thousand i think they gave me what it
was worth
okay so this money is for the car that's
not for any injuries or anything like
that
yes sir sorry about that oh that's okay
i'm just saying so you were driving a
ten thousand dollar car
they gave you ten thousand dollars
approximately and
now you buy a ten thousand dollar car
right what's wrong with that plan
um well um i'm trying
it's been hard finding a car because i
commute i want to get
um a car that's reliable you were
driving a 10
000 car yes sir
before and we were not having this
discussion about reliability
okay um okay okay i guess
sounds like you're overthinking it or
trying to try to no you're trying to use
this as an excuse to move up in cars
yeah like you like you're gonna win
something you didn't win anything they
just made you whole
if you if you break even on this deal
you you come out really good or if you
move down in car you come out really
good
so what was the car you were driving
that got killed
it was a 2012 camry okay
not a bad card another one of those 2012
camera is pretty reliable
yeah yeah it was amazing i loved it i
bought cash for it and i was really
upset
that it got um so found an amazing
2012 camry for ten thousand dollars
because that's what that one was worth
okay all right um all right is that okay
yeah i'm i was really wanting something
that would get me better gas mileage
because i can use to work
than a camera yeah my camera did
it did well it did okay um i just you
know not an f-150
i mean so okay what are you thinking
about
okay let me just settle this all right
dude
it will be a mistake please do not for
your sake
use this horrible tragedy as an excuse
to go further
up in car and set yourself back
financially
and you are rationalizing your butt off
i can hear it
so here i'll tell you um so what i was
but i was thinking my husband just set
the record straight my husband thinks
that we should pay this money to pay off
the debt
but it's cause then you would not have a
car
right exactly that's what i'm thinking
yeah so i
i want to use it for a car but i want to
finish paying off our debt
because we're really really close i want
to finish paying off our debt and then
just save like a couple
just a couple more thousand dollars to
get myself something that's got
low mileage and that will do well like a
prius
lindsey think about it this way getting
in a car wreck
was not a scratch-off ticket
you did land with ten thousand dollars
in your pocket and if you were walking
to work
then maybe this is a different
conversation but you need a good car to
get you to and from
and the insurance company did what they
were supposed to do and they made you
whole
and what you're trying to do is figure
out how to make be whole plus
and you can't okay i just want you to
get back to where you were
just get back to zero that's not worse
not better that's right you didn't win
anything
and the insurance did what they're
supposed to do they paid you and so go
get that same car back
and then move on with your day and don't
overthink it okay now
you know if you if you owed 80 000 on
the car or 50 000
on the car and this paid the car off and
got you out of a mess
and we could move you down in car we
would talk about that but your car is
very reasonable
don't move up and and set yourself back
and use some of the money you should
have been using for debt
but you're also not required to move
down to a two thousand dollar car
either in this situation so if i woke up
in your shoes
i would buy a ten thousand dollar car
they got good gas mileage
and by the way there's prius on the
market with they're for ten thousand
dollars absolutely
yeah and i'm not sure that's moving up
in cars
well played i i also understand
you owe very little money left and
you've got a ten thousand dollar check
in your
account and i get that's hard yeah but
you can't be you don't be careless i
mean no you can't
but but i get it and then you got to go
on and get a car right
if that was going to work you would have
been had the car for sale sign in the
car when it got totaled
and that's that's that's where she's not
able to make that leap right
and we think that when we get an
insurance settlement we win
you didn't man that's not what that's
supposed to be no it's supposed to make
you whole
believe me here insurance settlement and
win are never in the same sense right
right that never works that way so good
question thank you for calling yeah i
love that heart